alors vous savez dans cette émission il
ya une rubrique qui s'appelle tout le
monde en a parlé c'est le best of de
l'émission de la semaine passée ça n'a
pas changé
vous aimeriez avoir un nez
supplémentaires un oeil supplémentaires
un doigt un sexe et si c'était un chèque
supplémentaire lequel
bas le sexe de mon amant gaza enfin le
bras d'honneur confrères gonzesses on
aura un sexe de femme pas loin juste l'a
interpellé qu'est ce que tu fais tu vois
je baise
c'est très excitant il ya une scène
d'amour au bureau page 280
d'éviter aux gens d'acheter tout le
livre donc vous allez vous connaissez
l'adage 280 vous pensez pas que ça
pourrait faire un
sur tf1 ça ferait un film enfin un
téléfilm et enfin ça coûte cher parce
qu'il ya des costumes ouais bon sens
même les connaissent et ils sont un peu
loin mais parler
des 24 ans vous mesurer à m 118
voitures et les yeux bleus non ça je dis
pas ça
je tiens justement tour de poitrine zèle
une idée vous j'ai pas sa polaire d'été
et nordine à
85 non mais ça va vous pensez qu'il
faudrait que j'en ai honte non non pas
du tout vous pensez que les chiens avec
les petites poitrines c'est bien sonné
l'alarmé sur les chiennes de garde moi
je vais rentrer non moi si je pouvais
me rendent mieux compte mais ça va pas
être facile
y'a pas moyen de jeter un coup d'oeil
sénateurs non j'ai fait une petite
ambiance spéciale de plage le soir
un peu moins fort et là et c'est la
douche
et les limites de la chaîne dow
s'échange nommé jean jacques des
grillons le tour tu vois là les chiottes
et le maïs tasci ouvert et on entend un
peu des grillons échelle doit elle fuit
quelle ambiance qui la reçoit veut
gagner des millions qui est des
gouvernants méric dans la regza valeur
julio iglesias
entend plan votre propre frère
christophe colomb
exactement alors dit marc en tongs là
on l'a surtout vu en bd c'est pas sûr
qu'ils existent
mon frère c'est un concile avait
découvert quelque chose quand j'hésite
est qu'au lieu que les examens de la vue
du public
excusez moi d'insister ça a l'air un
petit peu obsessionnel n'est pas de sens
non plus vous êtes obsédé je suis pas
jalouse pas plus que ça christelle alors
ça vous dérange en pas par les barrages
ou pour un non non non
on vous appelle comanche à charles
napoléon prince monseigneur ta peau napo
mais comme vous voulez c'est un peu gens
un peu dingue quoi
j'ai participé et charles
ouais
mais c'est le prodige populaire
il fait dépuceler en fait par une
prostituée noire alors je signale la
page 43 avalanche
de 180 ch et poires c'est l'amour sur un
bureau et le dépucelage de frais moeurs
et c'est page 43 connaissez la légende
et twitter est étrange de les entendre
dire mais voilà on avait chanté on avait
été écoutée acheté par un million deux
cent mille personnes et puis après on a
appris à chanter sont sortis de le
besoin je vais faire de produire un
million deux cent mille personnes qui
ont cru qui chantait
comme c'est la rentrée michel dernier à
faire une interview rentrer quand je
pose des questions à nos amis franck
philippe et adèle cette fois 9
50 56 65 63
c'est pas ça c'est que j'ai pas compris
la question c'est cette attitude en fait
dans la foi cette [ __ ] 72 non pas 60
dollar était de vous droguez on peut le
dire je crois que c'est ça fait une
semaine maintenant vous avez rien pris
24 heures c'est bien parce que j'ai un
art est un patch anti héroïne un koala
examen de vos pattes c'est bien vous à
gauche monaco k-way d'accord le crack
juste la
première tentative de suicide
pourquoi vous ai jamais ici de vous
suicider c'est vrai que le nutella ça
tue quand même
c'est pas de faire ça
moi j'ai très petit bras dont jaar xfx
avec c'est très vexant pour moi j'avais
pris mais j'ai très petit bras je vais
essayer mais c'est très vous allez
essayer oui
livre qui sort chez michel lafon qui
s'appelle tu préfères trois petits
points à vie et tu préfères tu préfères
tu préfères mais pour toute la vie faire
sentir venir le danger ou sentir les
pieds voilà c'est ça va la vie au père
lui c'était vraiment l'image d'épinal il
laboure et audebert avec l'arrivée
encore avec pas
revenons à ces jeunes qui nous intéresse
c'est quand même un peu durcies roulé
noir est bâillonnée on ferait pas mieux
comme bien alors pardon laurent dorique
10 et un conteneur et coutumes
ce prions gps de maladie de la vache
folle maintenant c'est plus seulement
quand tu mange de la viande c'est à dire
que tu es en [ __ ] tu peut choper un
prion attention s'il vous plaît
avant-hier à la france jean ba dans ce
cadre précis pour faire l'amour un steak
tartare donc
le mot le plus con en amour c'est merci
encore où oui oui
ça dépend du jour sans doute
tous les gens qui sont sur le plateau il
est ce qu'ils faisaient ce qu'ils le
souvenir qu'il garde ses souvenirs des
blessures des femmes ils ont aimé qu'ils
ont quittée savate du back raté sur
lesquels les gens croient pas qu'ici non
c'est ça qui fait kiffer de l'année
excusez moi j'en mette en mer 20
kenny 6 millions de dollars enfin oui
mais ça fait quoi 30 millions salon tu
vois les buts la drogue sur la ville
ce qui est plus sexy en vous
que c'est à dire 6 millions de dollars
bien comme mec jonas est reparti
a compté pourtant donné un traitement
entre
ce que vous préférez dans le sexe le
goût allez vas-y
que je suis et je ne l'aimé ce sourire
là je vois sourire ça me fait plaisir
aussi ah ben ça c'est réglé c'est tout
ce que je voulais aller génériques
chantés
vous êtes à paris parce qu'à votre 77e
disque qui sort à la 77e sans être
obligé de le dire je ne fais pas et
chaque année
c'est le jour de votre anniversaire et
voilà votre cadeau
je vous avais pas dit ça m'arrive à vous
ça c'est le cadeau de julio
je sais vous cachez pas votre petite
amie vous êtes la première à dire oui je
me tue tamis s'appelle pascal et ses non
moins tout va bien les gens croient que
miss france et vierge moi je pensais ça
c'est ça oui j'étais persuadé que linda
hardy était vierge
[Applaudissements]
et amicale fond c'était une histoire
très sexuée d'ailleurs alors toi tu le
prends
tu continues tu quand tu descends du pjd
centraux actuels montrent
je passe tout paris et le manager
j'arrive à l'adoption françaises ont
passé au moins ne reçoivent aucune
chanson ici à la démission gt gt gt qui
se passe je vais te faire après comment
comment
mareva est ce que vous êtes masoe ce que
vous aimez quand on vous fait mal ça
dépend où
sa défense
pour et comment ça dépend où et comment
ne vous êtes pas content le principe
je les adore cette mère aimait les
cassettes pornos vous regardez des films
et ouais
quand vous dormez tout seul chez vous le
soir vous avez pas peur je m'enferme à
ses chiens c'est pas pratique pour
vous est incroyablement sexy francis
huster comment est-ce que vous résister
aux sollicitations féminin je pense à
christiane à arès et la chance de ma vie
comme cadeau un sac lesté annoncé
bien je suis moche je suis mal foutu
j'ai des jambes maigres vous avez des
gens de make way mareva
pour ça c'est pas la jambe
qu'est ce que vous avez dit balle pour
le caddie là c'est l'un des méchants
intérêts profiter mes poches parce que
sinon vous allez avoir des petites
surprises
format 100 g / mois d'août
et une scène dans le bouquin de massimo
où il dit il me fallait posséder la star
la plus célèbre du monde mais sinon il
va dans le noir ça s'est passé dans le
noir avec la tagab c'est el ghoul et
noir absolu se trouve c'était pas grata
garbo
il avait 81 ans était là et en chasse de
chair fraîche plus ni qu'est-ce qui fait
massimo qu'est-ce qui fait il boit un
petit coup de champagne pour s'en donner
un bout de pain beaucoup
de bouteilles et alors torch est obligé
arrivée le lendemain vous êtes chez le
notaire et vous allez votre appartement
rue de la faisanderie
quand même plus rue de la faisanderie
elle n'avait pas fait l'amour depuis
longtemps donc dit massimo il me semble
à pénétrer une jeune vierge c'est ça
c'est le cinéma qui s'est massivement
quel est pour vous il va naître un peu
le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
sans la plage on apprenait aussi
et on sait jamais ce qui va se passer a
trop la la la la
alors bon sur votre histoire d'amour
avec donald trump j'avais une question à
poser mois mais est ce que c'est vrai
qu'il vous a donné ses testicules en
boucle d'oreille
mon dieu qu'est ce qu'il m'a donné pour
maintenir la traductrice était en train
de une scène que j'aime beaucoup je peux
vous dire vous avez dessin magnifique
merci des 95 b extrêmement ferme vous
êtes connaisseurs
c'est foutu bourgade ça fait trois
heures je la travaille c'est en boîte
une
rafale et d'ailleurs qui arrivent et qui
ramassent le morceau
et je suis le bellâtre et va chez le
coiffeur
alors c'est surtout il faut voir un
monstre il ya des feux d'artifice et
quand ça beaucoup d'effets spéciaux de
technique alain delon passe aussi
derrière quand on passe à poil alain
delon à toi là et non via l'un deux ans
à poil dans mon spectacle ça tu pourras
le rajouter aux petits losc en fout
le vrai nom de plavix et das tient
chaud chaud chaud le beau petit bonhomme
en mousse
playmobil
bonus n'ont qu'à dix heures
tu veux pas que ça manque un peu de fil
annoncé mais non mais non pas moins
scola des patrons
regardez qui avait jeûné non c'est non
on ne touche pas seulement les espoirs
passé c'est super c'est là c'est la
première émission qui rit c'est la
première émission qui voit passer le q2
pas faim
à défaut je vous donne un micro avec moi
j'ai toujours le micro avec moi il est
vrai et c'est de là qu'ils sont bien
équipés
[Musique]
vous êtes un peu tout seul là là je suis
tout seul célibataire tout seul vous
voulez lancer un appel à télévision
tu cherches un québécois avec hans qui
porte une serpillière
appel au 0 800 plaisir
c'est là pour toi
par contre j'ai essayé de d'endormir
monfils ya 24 heures avant ouais pas mal
aux dents et qui est votre avis
précédents ouais il fait ses dents tu
verras quand il casse les couilles tu
vas pas de
scénario les mains
[Musique]
yami no name
vous êtes d'origine arménienne il aurait
marqué un péno contre l'armée nuage
passe quelque part tu veux que l'étude
reconnaissent le génocide du peuple et
quand tu as ton peut même onze pris les
allures importants comme avoir fumé est
amer
sport
ce dimanche miss auvergne à aurillac
enfin et ça continue comme ça que je me
tète un mail à dépenser
alors maintenant on va baisser la
lumière et on va se la faire
interview dernier coup geneviève de
fontenay
vraiment autant ça qu'on s'en va bien
geneviève dernier coup dur si tu réponds
ans après il va te dire dernier comme ou
presque
baffie maintenant je vais vous et moi si
j'avais épousé deux parties seraient pas
aussi mal élevé trois mois
je ne laisserai pas dire du magic xavier
wissant et javier zanetti
d'ailleurs il y en avoir une deuxième
petite fille xavier vient d'avoir une
deuxième petite fille bravo et xavier
c'est bien une petite fille il a bien
été obligé de mettre sa zigounette
pour arriver avec trish quand tu pars de
canal c'est long il ya un temps de
réponse très long mais pour être pauvre
quand on ne croit arrive c'est long
aussi avant que par le pognon c'est très
malin de mettre le plus de l'abbé pièce
que tu sais dit d'appeler dégueulasse
parce que c'est pal avec l'air du coup
c'est ta soeur thérésa votre premier
boulot c'est quoi j'ai vendu des
téléviseurs j'avais convaincu le gat
était venu pour me vendra que s'il les
prêtait avec une antenne pendant
quelques jours il ya de grandes chances
qu'ils auraient pu envie de le laisser
repartir je ne s'était pas déjà une
façon de piéger le gogo ça ne veut pas
l'accuser d'être un mauvais vendeurs de
ça non mais je l'accuse parlement côté
des vendeurs qui te vendent un truc qui
te disent regarder l'écran dans 30 ans
j'y suis chaponost télé
[Applaudissements]
vous le grand charmeur le beau parleur
trois mois et demi
de prison sans femmes à six mois alors
pardon alors c'est pire justement 100
femmes est-ce que c'était pas trop dur
ça comme tout le monde j'ai regardé
canal+ alors
tapie n'était pas très content 1
info contactez regarde derrière
pour le moment les garçons c'est un peu
comme les gâteaux c'est un peu
l'interdît quoi depuis ce s'arranger
maintenant les diabétiques un cigare
mais je préfère les
italiens moi je suis ni si moi j'ai des
chances quand même
alors claude allègre est ce que vous
aimeriez avoir un nez supplémentaires
année supplément n'est supplémentaires
supplémentaires un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe supplémentaires j'aimerais
avoir un oeil supplémentaire derrière
toi tu as peur de te remettre
aujourd'hui quand vous dites finalement
le mammouth c'est sympa je préfère
dinosaures parce que c'est encore plus
préhistorique que les mammouths ces
images du dinosaure et plus est
meilleure que celle du mahmoud accord ou
à ce qu'il faut beaucoup de temps pour
les du cerveau à la koala c'est du vécu
et puis à partir de là
vous pouvez pas savoir ce qui aura
marqué dans le prochain big voilà et est
ensuite passée nous la pétoche côté
peut-être pas de prochain bouquin cette
europe
ou encore
les stops
pourquoi christine
je crois vraiment ça m'amuse pas quoi
mais pourquoi on s'amusait bien où ma -
non
balle est partie 1 quand je vois les
guignols de l'info qui ouvre le yom
kippour
avec un soldat israélien avec une
mitraillette qui tirent sur des enfants
dans les marionnettes des guignols et
qui dit pardon pardon je trouve ça mais
honteux je trouve ça monstrueux de faire
sa
chance au numéro 9 je veux l'interprète
[Musique]
je ne regardais ça je m'en
sortir gagnant
voici henri salvador
je voulais
vous changeriez quoi si vous aviez une
baguette magique
beh web a voulu dire
maîtriser tous vos muscles un par un je
ne sais pas non je n'irai pas jusque là
mais c'est vrai qu'on a j'ai réussi à
scorer par exemple j'avais déjà
est ce que vous êtes géronto ah oui par
rapport au dollar par rapport à tout le
monde comme répondre à voir à moi aussi
c'est quand on aime les gens plus âgés
visage et corps visage et l'ont acquise
en plus pourquoi pas vous avez quel âge
j'ai bientôt 28 ans a fait 38
et ça va continuer jusqu'à ce qu'on la
met en circulation dans douze ou
quatorze 14 mois par bon est-ce que vous
suivez aurait dit
j'ai un peu décroché là je pense à autre
chose à bombay sa voix et ses démons
i
ol et vous me dites en arrivant thierry
je veux plus voir de danseurs je vais me
changer les idées j'aime changer la tête
etc je vous présente au quelqu'un qui
vous change la tête quand même alors
vous êtes né en 49 mais on sait qu'on
sait pas grand chose sur vous et oui et
ça nous intéresse pas non plus
[Applaudissements]
quelle est votre première pensée quand
vous trouvez à un homme séduisant
change et 33 vous méfier de vous mettre
dans son mari tu vas l'avoir traversé ma
tuque au cumin
est ce que vous croyez à l'efficacité
des crèmes antirides
certaine c'est bien faisait main si
vraiment ça vous va très bien mais c'est
moi qui suis vraiment qu'est ce que tu
as peur
le gros
est une façon de vous dire vous êtes
jolie
et sa façon à lui de faire des
compliments son chien et puis un peu
balourd mais bon là le seul
mais quelle histoire d'amour
et sur les yeux
vous portez way et les lentilles
spéciales qui valent 55 mille francs la
paire quelques primeurs alors il y a
personne au fond de l'eau
pour votre préparation pas de tabac pas
d'alcool pas de filles ouais pendant la
descente et la remontée est
bon alors baissé y en a et je me
dis peuvent mais tu voulais vous avez
rocher là
oui
on va écouter c'est le respect
voilà ah ouais
mais le béa oui
désolé à
20,4 il me dit en régie que vous arrêtez
pas de regarder 6 1 pour toi
[Applaudissements]
si vous deviez posséder la moitié d'un
homme vous préféreriez avoir le haut ou
le bas
mais là je pense que si nous avons ou
non parce que là il y avait une solution
ou alors tu passer pour quelqu'un de
romantique où tu passer pour une super
chaude faites moi monsieur guy rouquet
déchets
qui a des roues qui dit pourquoi je
rentre pas sur le placer
c'est vrai que guy roux même à marseille
ça pourrait
jamais français ils m'ont toujours fait
un accueil formidable je sais pas
pourquoi chaque fois que je vais à
marseille ils ont le droit comme ça
bonsoir
voila je reste comme ça ça y est je suis
bien je suis installé tout va bien merci
en voie
d'être venu
westhoff m'enfin bon c'est pas le même
usage
histoire sagittaire ça marche vierge et
sagittaire gunther
vierge il faut que je viens de livres
vous avez dit un truc toute façon qui va
en calmer beaucoup vous avez dit les
hommes d'un soir ne m'intéresse pas
histoire sérieuse romantique avec
beaucoup des choses beaucoup de
discussions
c'est ça c'est bien c'est mais des fois
ça fait du bien aussi
première fois de baisser tellement
garçons ah bon vous pourrez vous exercer
à dire comme ça je vais pas vous
demander la première fois à troyes parce
qu'ici non parce qu'ici on est ici on
est discret non je demanderai pas la
première fois trois premières fois 4
parce que vous êtes très brillant vous
expliqué très simplement que la
différence entre l'égalité et l'équité
l'égalité c'est très simple c'est qu'on
rembourse chacun de nous quand on a une
défense un accident de santé la même
manière l'équité ça consiste à mieux
aider ceux qui en ont le plus besoin à
rembourser à 100% un enfant d'exclus
aubervilliers pas nécessairement à 100%
un enfant de cadre dirigeant qu'ils
attrapent est un peu froid sur les
pentes de courchevel je peux vous
demander à quel âge de les fumer votre
premier pétard parce que ça c'est de la
provocation facile première ligne
mais je m'en cache pas c'est vrai que je
n'ai pas toujours été avec défi super
mignonne mais avait quelque chose devant
la folie 50 ans a fait un gros boudin
[Applaudissements]
je demande à michel kopka qui dirige
france 2 une prime de risque je ne peux
pas faire cette émission je ne peux plus
faire cette émission que tu es comment
les bonnes
c'est bon
c'est bon salut ma réponse je suis
excité pourtant vous avez déclaré à 50
ans on commence à décembre quand vous
aviez 50 ans maintenant vous en avez 60
vous pensez quoi sexagénaire ouais ça
disent que ça dit ouais sexe âge et
n'est as
moi j'ai envie de m'asseoir là
vous faites le tour il n'y a pas de
souci alors qu'il montait dans un bar
savate 6-10
ans va mal
il est toujours inscrit à l'udf
c'est quoi l'idée f
et
moi
et ça baise à l'hosto non à ça doit
baiser losc
s'est pas encore remis son c'est là où
j'ai rencontré ma femme voilà
aujourd'hui bienvenus
c'est vous les enfants ça vous rappelle
quoi c'est bien mais c'est pas ça vaut
pas quand même plastic bertrand colin
j'ai bien aimé la chanson voyage voyage
mois
vous étiez un virus
quelque chose sur internet
l avion à l'avenir
je vais bosser
il ya 4000 écoute on écoute les
téléphones portables on écoute les facs
et on fait des écoutes thématiques par
exemple on vous fait le hit parade sur
le mois les trois numéros que vous
appelez le plus combien dure la
conversation ici c'est vous qui appelez
ou si c'est la personne qui vous appelle
et à partir de ça on arrive à faire une
toile d'araignée on vous met au milieu
vous en sortez
je précède le mondial ne sait pas c'est
que c'est un personnage historique
le fait d'être fliqué sans arrêt comme
ça moi je trouve ça insupportable
j'aime pas la police quoi il ya un
moment donné j'ai demandé un flic quand
j'étais en garde à vue jeudi mais vous
n'êtes pas gardiens de la paix une non
monsieur je suis fonctionnaire de police
attend c'est quoi ça gardiens de la paix
pour moi ça voulait dire quelque chose
mais fonctionnaires de police va te
faire voir à quoi va te faire voir
used il suit la côte en bateau et vous
vous achetez un mobile-home
nobilo et des vies celui-là coton qui
voit le bateau dans la mer il avance
pour pas quitté un ouais c'est beaucoup
mais c'est beau au lycée vous tombez
amoureux d'un garçon mais s'appelle
vient de guerre tu sais ça hein
et il est là ce soir
effet 120 kg
qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus chez
dave a fait de sa coiffure
c'est à nous d'aller chercher ma fille
charles qu'est ce qui vous énerve le
plus
sanon coiffure chez moi
ca trù bien coiffure
le péché qui vous tente le plus
la luxure quoi l'art est déjà quand
j'étais petit on me disait que j'étais
pervers qu'il était moche av ouais on
peut devenir que pas un peu les deux
chats
parfois je suis déjà que j'ai dit des
choses que je ne pense pas ou alors il
n'y avait pas ce qu'il faut j'ai vérifié
un quota de conneries je bois du pays
d'aix dans le mobile
mélo
acte sexuel il ya une sorte
d'antagonisme de luttes de pouvoir et en
même temps de chaires de recherche de la
dissolution et de l'union passé chirac
mais qu'est-ce qu'il est con mais je le
savais mais qu'est ce que
c'est fou les yeux et vicieux de la même
couleur berling et dave oui c'est vrai
que c'est beau ouais ça change non
je ne dis pas que je suis ministre a
météo je dis que quand il fait beau
alors si vous le dites maintenant elle a
lâché ses
deux métiers la présence d'un mini c'est
la première fois de votre vie que celle
ci s'est même amusé des fous-rires tête
j'adore ça que les cas une merde c'est
pour vous
je sais vous était pas comme ça avant
l'été beaucoup sous le pied trotskiste
vous est ce que vous savez que le
j'espère a été accusée dit on oui à
moins que son frère ont dit que celui où
l'on sait pas en faire le scoop c'est
que il faisait partie de ma cellule ah
c'est vrai ça je revois ce blondinet
c'est énorme la donner j'ai connu
réellement un jeu c'était lui ou son
frère alors voilà j'en suis au même
point de vous ah oui d'accord vous ai
connu un jeu se plaint trotskisme on
sait pas si c'est lionel le cantal et la
rectrice ton fauteuil défraîchi
catherine se chamaillent
plus rapide que moi plus rapide et puis
moi insultant pour les sombres et
surtout
vous détestez descendus sur foot et en
même temps
il
j'ai reçu un email d'un dénommé laurent
picone qui est un français qui habitent
en hollande et qui me dit ma femme et
moi on a décidé de faire un enfant et de
l'appeler serge et quand l'enfant sera
né en lui offrira un chien et on
l'appellera magne et où
on a tout le temps envie de vous dire
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas l'air content
sourit et souriez pour voir la haye
sur son scénario on me dit vous serez en
costume de lin blanc sur une plage avec
une très belle jeune fille qui va vous
servir des pompes et puis un mec qui va
vous éventé derrière et vous allez poser
votre main dans un sac de loukoums et
l'autre main sur un ca oui bon c'est
plus à faire que d'aller tourner
germinal dans le dans les corps
il faut faire les ensembles quand on est
vieux d'abord parce qu'on il en est pas
longtemps et
francis blanche et nous on nous mettait
tout le temps dans le fond et alors le
metteur en scène alizés alesi parlez
parlez entre vous quand on savait plus
pas dire on avait un code et on disait
je suis catholique comme vous ça c'était
le
français deezer je suis fatiguée elle
j'ai mangé traque mondiale était très
difficile et puis je suis rentré tard la
maison et puis moi je vais vous dire je
suis catholique comme vous
alors je savais qu'il dirait plus rien
il fallait que j'enchaîne alors jeu mais
qu'est ce que vaut la peau de
plaisanterie facile
moi aussi je jusqu'à ce que jean de
suspense plus rien et moi aussi je suis
ta télécom est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
fait un petit peu la maline en acceptant
de ce film we say die je vais y arriver
qu'après quand vous étiez devant rocco
siffredi ce témoin à mon avis les yeux
plus grands que le bas ventre
ce que vous avez de plus sexy en vous
mais ça
non sans déconner
on doit vous atteler comme henri
d'orléans monseigneur toujours vraiment
seigneur et puis si c'était mon seigneur
ou ma couille
vous pourrez choisir les kivu entre
laure sinclair anne sinclair ou bob
sinclair lors
lors d'accord que tous les jeux footon
ayant longtemps vécu au maroc gérant à
l'arraché vivien alors j'ai vécu pauvre
pas mal d'années à larache aussi mais
j'suis auch bien ouais
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien parce qu'à ses services
guitton s'apparente à gueule
non je pense à peut-être avoir l'air en
r peut-être un peu angélique
physiquement mais pas l'être du tout de
caractère vous n'êtes pas à l'intérieur
on me regarde pas un mais je ne crois
pas j'attends vous attendez quoi
c'est pas pour raconter des c est
pourquoi vous êtes a payé le loyer
pendant dix ans je n'avais pas d'argent
pour vous pensé quand on n'a pas
d'argent on paye pas y'a pas dû me fier
pour la mention mais attends t'es gentil
mustapha il paye pas et va en taule et
lui on lui dit rien
j'ai bien compris il ya deux poids et
deux mesures mustapha et monseigneur et
30 de france et tour qui lui bien elle
m'a d'accord j'ai gagné tout c'est
normal vous faites vos courses à leur
marché moi ça m'amuse beaucoup de savoir
que le roi de france fait ses courses à
leur marché chez le chat l'endroit on
rencontre des gens
imaginez vous ayez commis un crime
monseigneur acquis demanderiez vous de
vous aider à cacher le corps à mon
épouse dans les cantines scolaires
cantine scolaire il ya des énormes
marmite
les momies savent pas ce qu'ils mangent
on en rajoute un peu de purée séjour
vous savez que naomi campbell ne parlent
pas bien le français romain avoir
recours à une traductrice et nous avons
la chance d'avoir ce soir parmi nous
belinda bonsoir belinda bonsoir
andré leon talley dit en parlant de vous
naomi cambell un fessier si haut si
stable si ferme qu'on pourrait poser une
flûte de champagne dessus est utilisé
comme table à cocktail
essayons ce soit
est ce qu'on peut nous apporter du sang
tan
vous avez choisi ou pas
ok c'est le vieux où le
répète on admet
m
[Applaudissements]
quand on voit tous ces tops models
anorexique et quand on sait ce qu'on les
paye on se dit que ça fait cher le kilo
et vous avez connu beaucoup d'hommes
orson welles c'est vrai qu'il voulait
que vous quittiez tout pour le suivent
en amérique
c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai quel bord or cet or sma
des gens après il m'a dit j'étais
amoureux fou de toi je n'étais pas à
faire avant elle vous l'a dit après oui
est ce que vous préférez attention c'est
très grave ça mais un mec qui bosse bien
mecha infidèles ou un mec lieberman mais
qui fit d'elle ni l'un ni l'autre ah bon
je recherche un troisième a weak et
fidèle
on vous a marié un peu comme jeanne
moreau des apps que tous les tous les
hommes qu'on vous a attribué vous n'avez
pas eu obligatoirement non mais il y en
a qu'on a pas
l oublier son verre non mais ah si vous
buvez longueur donner envie tu as tu vas
connaître ses pensées
vas-y vas-y dis moi ce que tu dis moi ce
qu'elles pensent samedi aux mondiaux
mais mon dieu
mais l'histoire
je peux je peux essayer d'aller
combattre avec trop
allez
savoir plus et les pensées de 4
à dire sérikpa dire un truc drôle
ce qui me
gêne
[Applaudissements]
ouais bravo
alors publié la machine à trahir chez
denoël attention
faites par une variante moi je fais des
moulinets en même temps que permettrait
d'être indiscipliné comme je le suis
dans d'autres enceintes maternelle
à revel c'est un punk
bon il a publié un livre
belinda c'est votre single chaque fois
où vous viendrez dans cette émission il
y aura ça
au revoir belinda
visage est bien là non c'est pas mal
hein franchement là c'est bien le
maintien à l'arrêt de bus et je vous
regarde ma beaucoup savez je regarde
très baissier parce que le problème en
fait c'est ça c'est ça je vois que vous
vous n'avez absolument rien si si j'ai
apprécié je mets profil c'est
vous et choqué beaucoup de monde quand
même avec votre mercedes vitres fumées
sur la roue et je vous fait allumer des
cigarettes par les assistants ne trouvez
pas que c'est un peu too much pas douter
vous savez moi je vais vous dire quand
on a réussi après tout c'est ça ouais
hein quand on a du pognon quand on a du
vent et on sait bien dans éclaboussé
tous les ans qu'à se démerder pour faire
les mêmes choses voilà
je suis pas brigitte bardot non plus
mais je trouve ça un peu
triste d'utiliser les animaux alors
qu'on n'a pas vraiment besoin c'est que
gilberto ce qui est bizarre à comprendre
c'est qu'elle défend les animaux elle
attaque les arabes frères mais de faire
en classe on l'appelle la girafe merci
vous appelez la girafe on sait pas qu'il
vaut probablement dès maintenant vous
êtes un symbole de volonté de rester
c'est le vilain canard voir quel
meilleur pied de nez pour faire à tous
ces gens qui s'accusait cependant prisa
exactement il ya un espoir pour tous ces
gens qui vous regardent
ces tâches moins fidèles alors
exactement ça va faire trois ans et demi
la girafe est monogame et falls a
préféré caresser ou vous faire caresser
ça dépend des jours aujourd'hui par
exemple
maintenant c'est sûr j'aurais été sur la
voyait arriver
gentil je travaille pour toi alors
zoom mon garçon vous le faites pas jack
de quoi
c'est possible
il a une phrase sur la modestie dans son
livre qu'est ce qui dit c'est l'art
d'être loué deux fois mais je te dis à
quelqu'un vous êtes charmant mais non
mais si
on a toujours envie de me faire plaisir
aux gens vous voir sourire fait des
heureux
une injure va [ __ ] le comté mort qui
tâche il a souvent pris à maudite des
cas de sir paul dumont vous gagnez
combien
l'an dernier j'ai gagné 20 millions de
francs bruts c'est-à-dire 7 millions de
francs mais
moi j'ai la chance d'être à la tête d'un
groupe qui créent des emplois je trouve
ça plutôt bien de la même manière que
quand on voit la richesse créée par des
entreprises que les salariés en aient
leur tour au travers de l'epargne
salariale
je trouve ça normal
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous pensez sérieusement
qu alain de greef est encore l'homme de
la situation en tant que directeur des
programmes de canal plus
ce que je crois c'est que alain de greef
et un homme de programme remarquable par
seulement derrière pour les programmes
de canal+ mais pour l'ensemble des
chaînes thématiques et des différentes
offres de canal un ami arrive chez vous
à l'improviste en pleine nuit qu'est ce
qui vous choque le plus ce qu'ils
trouvent sur votre table de nuit c'est
que j'ai fait appel à du recel a imaginé
et loire mein kampf ou un godemiché mein
kampf manigances et quoi balladur mein
kampf aussi mais c'est ce que c'est
qu'un god
bien sûr qu'il soit sûrs qu'ils auront
tous
je vais dire à un extrait de votre livre
non mais j'ai pris un extrait savent pas
rassurez vous j'ai fait mine de la
vouloir à quatre pattes c'est ça vous
avez un truc sauf ces foutus de ma
gueule là ça sert de passagers + porno
du bouc l'an passé le plus soft en même
temps si tu as raison
je vais respecter des règles inepte
quand on connaît ça y est ils décident
de google
[Applaudissements]
puis à la fin qui passe un gage que
j'écrirais ça c'est ici j'étais très
clean pendant l'émission bah si tu dis
ok tu as joué le jeu à la fin que joue
le jeu et qui fait ce qui sera écrit sur
un patin alors qu'est ce que vous feriez
s'il vous restait 24 heures à vivre 24
heures à 6 heures si son jeu rallye 24
heures du monde
24 heures moi je pense à rien je ferais
rien su peut-être j'irai chez ikea je
montrais un homme
je viens de trouver le gage
elle cale tu devras te soumettre thierry
et jeux soumis l'idée au public qu'ils
ont l'air assez chaud
les seules personnes qui pensent plus à
l'argent que les riches ce sont les
pauvres arrêtés ils vont pas acheter le
livre
pas l'acheter
c'est quoi le casse alors t'as pas le
droit de le voir c'est à la fin
[Rires]
[Musique]
à
prenez reconnaît une
selle pour la pluie pour les tampons
s'était engagé en début dé mais si on
est d'accord enfin je me suis engagé non
vous pourriez mourir d'amour où tout le
monde peut voir des vrais pour faire une
réponse comme ça à julien
jeudi la soeur de vie vous n'êtes pas
sûr de lire ou du tout
en fait
en fait j'étais demi soeur de lio
vous pouvez toucher votre nom et votre
langue ouais c'est de voir à huawei
j'ai pas de pv j'ai pas de voiture
chanteuse j'ai pas
comme une mélodie poliment
on parle de la vache folle laurent c'est
important mais j'essaie mais qui
dit quoi c'est vous qui fait des gestes
obscènes ou tu vois toi tu balances
je montre les agents
quelle faille on sait bien
qu'elle est le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte
lee ah ouais vous n'êtes pas bon je dois
tâche et m'a attrapé dans la safrane
et le dopage ah je savais pour mettre
quand même pas fait attendre si tard
pour te faire une analyse d'uriné basse
il
faut qu'on inverse les rôles c'est le
gage que j'avais accepté allait bien
[Applaudissements]
on ne bouge pas pendant le génial
assez reposant qui permet mais là où tu
es très con c'est que j'ai été viré pour
la prochaine liste implique
ragots est-ce que je suis radio à
j'adore les ragots estat les ragots sur
la profession safem le dernier à qui
marche le mieux en ce moment c'est le le
restaurant de jean luc delarue qui
s'appelle la redevance parce que c'est
vous qui l'avez payé si vous étiez une
injure tu m'énerves sa cuisse et tout
mais tu es fou la violence de prométhée
oui mais bon mais je peux pas on va se
faire censurer tu es malade non mais ta
gueule
grotte vos merdes à vous dire [ __ ]
voir annonce est à voir dans mes jeux
plus
quand on voit dans le métier 1
vous réalisez qu'il faut avoir les seins
nus quand on fait danser au lido et l'a
déjà qu'il faudra mais ça
d'abord ensuite il faut les montrer
hélène est extrêmement pudiquement
viendra temps d'un jour
c'est une soirée je préfère me gênait
nous montre ses seins tu montres letia
si j'allais à ce moment je vais aussi
tranquillement 3 de choses
vous étiez nu dans le contenu du nid
c'était horrible ces gens n'étaient dans
sa 90
est ce que pendant les quatre jours que
vous avez passé là bas
non je ne fais pas un plan du corps est
ce que je vais faire la question qui tue
non plus oui géronto les vieux les vieux
de 51 ans
27e minute ou balancer le ballon dans
les tribunes vous engueuler avec
l'arbitré et vous avez vous jeté le
maillot à terre ce qui évidemment est
même tapis quelles épaules et de nommer
député enfin élu député il vous souvenez
plus à ce moment-là taper
dans les mains jamais soutenu ouais il
disait en parlant de vous si il faut le
mettre en clinique en le mettant en
clinique ouais on aurait pu se retrouver
ce qui faisait de moins sexy en gros je
me voyais comme vraiment quelqu'un de
sexy moi je ne suis jamais demandé si je
fais ce que je dis - fait qu'est ce que
vous préférez dans le sexe mon plaisir
c'est le plaisir de l'autre à écouter
celle ci je fais rien
et que je sens que mon partenaire à
prendre du plaisir à semer des réserves
voilà tu as dû son partenaire mon
partenaire sémaphore parce que
mais il ma femme ma partenaire
l'adresse du
canton à carlos et
si vous aviez une aventure vous lui
diriez votre jules
d'accord c'est l'arrivée vous êtes
marrants nouveau bah oui safari mais je
suis mariée depuis un an j'ai pas vous
dire qu après l'émission
pas si c'est un accident si c'est ça
c'est les accidents au
général il a glissé la presse je
m'excuse
et alors il y avait 4000 candidats sous
un chapiteau exacte des majorettes
superbe maurice erding et combien je
crois que j'ai été promis oui c'est ça
je te promet d'attirer une majorette oui
alors vous avez dit le sens c'est
compliqué hein c'est le sens en audience
est un non sens non l'audience un sens
et une audience sans l'audience sans
essence est un non-sens faut faire la
télé pas trop conne voilà c'est plus
c'est plus simple
vous la connaissez bien je connais bien
ghislaine je veux dire que je connais et
l'aisne j'ai eu la chance de la
connaître ailleurs que sur les plateaux
télé je dirais des balades en montagne
tout cela aulas attend dé vous en avait
trop dit ou pas
tout partait sur une île déserte est-ce
que vous préféré partir avec un mec très
beau ou une fille très laide fitr et
l'inde vous n'êtes pas [ __ ] du tout vos
mais pas du tout ouais mais non merci
j'avais lu ce à quoi vous préférez
préfet oui je préfère une fille très
lettre qu'un mec très beau avait de
toute façon au bout deux jours je trouve
un très bel donc
ça vous trouvez votre fiancée au lit
avec depardieu
ça c'est chiant qu'est ce que vous
faites je sodomise depardieu
catherine me dit c'est vrai qu'à three
la productrice de l'émission elle dit
pour un mec tu n'es pas pdc dominent
facilement depardieu
vous aimez donner du plaisir votre
partenaire plâtre il absolument
maintenir la ce sport qui va être
poursuivi majorée pour tourner alors et
fiori
[Rires]
si je me souviens d'un petit col comme
vous la prochaine vous le voulez non
mais j'aimerais bien être un savant oui
bah ouais ça c'est énorme et c'est à
partir du moment où tu vas mettre c'est
thierry plus de sexe
ça va bien mais vous l'avez mis à
l'envers mais ça fait râler parce que ça
fait un peu cogité comme ça
oui regarde c'est là où j'oublie de
mettre le doute de l'écran tout âge
alors que là et là et à rien elle a donc
elle a pris le 6 mai elle la gare
découvrir
une chanson ça
ça c'est une chanson elle a pris le
soleil il est séduisant elle a gardé
avec la face b au toit majorettes
c'était tout le monde en parle rendez
vous la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
j'étais marié non c'est pas trés rld
avec la championne du monde de
bodybuilding est-ce que physiquement
excusez moi c'est un peu un discret
comme question est ce qu'elle est excité
physiquement parce que c'est une
montagne de muscles si tu n'en était pas
elle c'est pas du tout ça c'est ce qui
veut dire ils n'osent pas le dire parce
qu'au fond il est humilié est-ce que
c'est pas un truc de [ __ ] de se taper
une culture histoire
est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour
je me souviens je me souviens j'étais il
y avait une petite place un arrêt de bus
et gisèle envoie ce garçon c'était mon
premier baiser avec la langue je me suis
retourné j'ai regardé mes copines mais
j'ai fait mes
premières cuites çà au monde
appelle le bernard c'était tellement
qu'un ravaillac 2000 par exemple si
l'arrivée et qui vous tuer thierry mois
serait bien à la merde ce ne sera jamais
pourquoi on ne bouge pas voir en bas qui
a essayé le secret est enfermé dans mon
coffre à la banque dans une enveloppe
scellée qu'on ouvrira à ma mort alors il
fallait que tu meures alors
que vos parents sont blancs et que les
votes sont noirs
et ça vous fait rigoler celle attendue
on songe à oui il faut dire que c'est
lui faut dire non à ces interviews mans
sans choisir le contraire de la vérité
oui
et vous ils sont noirs
évident
bien alors asia argento est ce que vous
êtes gérant tôt
ça dépend de l'âge cinquante deux ans
ces vieux 52 ans alors oui voilà et ben
voilà d'être grand amateur de deux
femmes et d'alcool tout le monde le sait
on ce n'est pas un secret pendant dire
grand amateur de femmes et d'alcool
c'est sexiste
nadine vous aimez les choses de la vie
dont les femmes et l'alcool ça va ça
j'y arriverai jamais j'aimais bien
baisés boire pas leurs
noms mais je sais moi ça me gène le dire
ça à moi personnellement j'aurais dit
vous êtes un grand amateur d'alcool et
de femmes je sais je sais mais chaque
hausse de 10 à peine 11 ans
devenu donc enfin vous champion du monde
des constructeurs et schumacher champion
du monde des pilotes voilà pas non plus
jean hugues anglade lui c'est laisser
les faits la wii c'est les guépards ont
même fait tatouer déconner
tu veux te voir
si vous êtes homo végéter violée à l'âge
de 13 ans par un pédophile donc avant
c'est vrai j'ai du mal dans ce cas là je
savais pas ça bah non personne ne le
savait ça c'était aussi la première fois
que je le dis c'est bien c'est courageux
de dire ça
avait dit bonsoir vous avez 20 ans vous
avez déjà fait vingt films x
professionnels 22 22
c'est encore mieux et vous avez aussi un
dock de philo vous l'avez eue à l'âge de
18 ans c'est pour ça qu'on vous appelle
19 les malades les chiffres ouais et
vous avez fait 1 68%
vient alors à 13 ans vous décidez de
plus manger de viande oui vous devenez
végétalienne ce qui n'est pas
végétarienne dans moi j'ai eu un fils
mais manger
est ce que quand on fait des effets de
la scion sur un plateau on peut en même
temps accumulé des points retraite
bas salaires ce type de questions mais
c'est une vraie question ce que vous
avez pu sexy en vo
tatouage en patois et où cet
oiseau à la la ça fait 2 à like j'aime
bien la chanson de glinda
friendster belinda
montré qu'en mai regarde les nids
peuvent être partout
le cadreur vous êtes prêts pour le
tatouage bye bye anastasia
g
vous dites pas le matin quand vous voyez
dans le miroir
non non non non deux je me dis je suis
moche mais mais mais c'est pas grave
parce que dans dix ans c'est dégueulasse
moi je dis en déconnant à tous mes
copains homosexuel je leur dis tous les
jours on n'en dormira un enfant tu sais
en lui disant et le brun charmant
embrassa le prince charmant et il ne se
marièrent bas ils n'eurent pas d'enfant
puisqu'il se bourrer r le cul jusqu'à
nos jours mais ils vécurent heureux
alors la libération de man est ce pas
bon c'est à mourir de rire balle à terre
il nous dira papon et les vieux et tout
c'est pas utile de laisser en prison ce
mec on aurait préféré l'enfermer qu'il
était jeune on en rêvait
on l'a eue de vieux
alors j'en ai deux fin je montre le
petit on va y aller au
et sinon y'a pas moyen de jeter un coup
d'oeil sur le moteur
monsieur philippe corti
paris
piché
tout au long des 1
on le voit la blancheur
un grand merci à hervé bourges qui s'est
prêté au jeu
ah ouais vous moi je suis né à sedan
suivent mais tous mais allez vous faire
[ __ ] ça je suis allée offert
en écharde isula c'est là j'étais un peu
tendu mais charlie son giga hervé bocher
soir ok
t'as la date de l'enterrement de mon
père c'est incroyable la façon dont tu
parles oui mais tu sais pas ce qu on
projette toujours et puis on dit un
accident peut vite arriver regarde par
andy par un peu nombreux sur la ficelle
puis avoir un accident contre vote
officiel c'est à dire qu'il peut y avoir
un accident
vous avez été interpellé en 83 dans une
bmw volée est dans la boîte à gants il
avait le pistolet voler un policier lors
de l'évasion de bruno sulak qui était
l'ennemi public numéro un j'ai piqué la
mauvaise bagnols si vous êtes de plus
sexy en vous
elle a dit les yeux le derrière ni les
cuisines la laïcité est obligé de bien
le faire
cadeau vous mettiez
si je mets le japon veut tout ce que je
puis non
à
l'ex patron du csa bonsoir monsieur le
président patron du c'est ça du tout
président et ce pour quoi j'avais bouche
ici
bien le bonsoir foutoir
vient chez vous je vous le dis c'est que
vous n'oubliez jamais ce qui au départ
vous avez et puis qui continuent de
travailler avec vous comme catherine
barma bravo
on était tous les deux convoqués je sais
pas quelle connerie elle avait fait
encore et ont été convoqués dans votre
bureau vous étiez président et puis vous
faites avant on fait ça edit ah vous
êtes phare total au président oui c'est
vrai j'aime pas qu'on en vous émission
vous poser la question sur le cabanis
caractérise et sa vidéo canon mais non
moi je moi je vais vous dire une chose
raison président moi je suis content on
est tous les deux bloqués dans un chalet
oui la 4 mètres de neige oui je meurs de
faim oui et pour pas mourir de faim vous
me manger vous commencez par quoi
réside en fait vous le dire par
l'oreille parce que quand je vais au
restaurant quelquefois j'adore manger
les oreilles de cochon
j'ai pas ajouté et c'est parce que le
placer les oreilles et la queue de
cochon et mais bon ça va bien là
j'ai été agressé dans ma à l'entrée de
ma chambre d'hôtel et on a su après que
le type avec fumée du cabanis donc je
fait d'avoir dû cabanis soit qui va vous
en parler tout qu'est ce que c'est ça
c'est quand on a trop fumée de cannabis
ont dit qu a banni les verriers entre
vous vous aussi c'est briser la glace
c'est vrai qu'on s'entendait bien et
puis un jour ça s'est fait naturellement
quand il a glissé il a pénétré
mais c'est dangereux patins président
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut avoir
des relations sexuelles la veille deux
camps ne le dira pas moi ça m'avait dit
tu arrives à nous poser cette question
avant alors moi je vais vous demander
jamais le jour de l'émission l'émission
jamais je garde mon énergie pour mes
amis téléspectateurs
nous avons saisi tu là
est-ce que prêtre avait caressé ou vous
faire caresser ou ça
est-ce que vous avez un fantasme non
encore assouvie par avec les pommes de
terre
j'ai pas tellement de fantasmes y'a pas
un truc vous dit comme ça j'aimerais
bien le faire j'aime bien moi c'est les
chiens sur la bouche au
jeu de patates dans les mains
on a été très discret il n'a pas fait
non
le rêve est passé
bon tu as une bonne clientèle et toutes
tes blagues ne rigole monsieur patate
est ce que j'y arriverai mois
des coups de poing souviens un jour
j'étais arrivé avec la gueule
complètement déformés je m'étais fait
déchirer la tronche dans une bagarre et
touche tu avais dit que je m'étais fait
choper dans métro avec ma femme
justement en fait j'étais allé dans une
soirée les potes et ça va terminer en
baston générale les mecs avaient dit du
mal de moi et tu m'avais défendu bcsa
voilà
est-ce que tu as toujours les nuits
blanches oui mais maintenant quand chez
les blanches c'est pour travailler c'est
plus pour sortir ce que tu te fout de
notre gueule
dernier coup de rein là ça fait un
moment là bas
parce que ça fait un mois et demi que je
suis donc en tournée que frédéric tu me
rejoins
demain bon [ __ ] je pensais que j'ai la
banane
les costauds sont champions du monde de
hand ball je peux permettre l'entrée
handball c'est quoi un bol il faut dire
football et handball voilà oui oui oui
oui ça n'est pas mes origines et le trou
de bad
est ce que vous détestez dans le sexe
qu'il faille que ce s'arrête la plupart
du temps de mon fait quoi c'est ça qui
est terrible pour être des makes mais
aussi demain
premier baiser
dans une boue à quel âge
13 12
mais en vérité son prénom
je pars si vous mentez cb oui c'est
bastia c'est bien vous êtes resté cinq
mois en sang froid aux bonnes réponses
première fois à troyes
enfin un ami
première fois quatre
pas encore dire vous
j'ai jamais pris de drogue de ma vie
n'ont jamais même pas le marin même pas
du cabanis
parce qu'en france on dit plus cannabis
main
qui l'imposé
bravo
et on dit aujourd'hui l'effet fernandes
n'a pas joué il ya plus que lui et après
jouer dur c'est qu'il t'apprécie pas
plus que ça
ça va se ressentir dans l'internet et
dans les couloirs et appelle le
baltringue
à trois victoires en 15 matches 30 une
contrainte contre thouars je ne veux pas
que ça existait là vous avez gagné
national 3e division qui est 32e de la
coupe de france en troisième division du
national 1 rue se sont joués sur la
route vers
thierry serait-il possible que tu te
mettes de dos j'aimerais voir ta nuque
c'est vous qui me poser une question à
moi
je l' ai vu je n'ai vu que ce qu'elle
est ce que tu
es en plus ouais comme une conne je
répète dans votre nouveau 10 vous faites
une chanson sur sur mantes la jolie oui
pour dire à ceux du val fourré que je
pense toujours à eux bien sûr d'ailleurs
un bon jour ils seront alloués à bonjour
mantes la jolie oui bien sûr je dis à
tous mes amis dose de demont jour mantes
la jolie
et bonjour les minguettes non c'est
spécial dédicace à tous les pitbulls
êtes croyant
bien sûr crois qu'un jour les attentions
pour marcher ouais première cuite et je
crois en pologne première cigarette au
cabanis ya pas très longtemps c'était à
la jamaïque web a marqué vous vous
bourrez en pologne vous fumez vous fumer
de l'herbe à la jamaïque vous êtes lui
arrive quelque chose au bon endroit où
j'ai une chose qui arrive j'aime pas
quand dans vos émissions vous posez la
question sourire cas kadhafi
votre premier souvenir
le sourire de ma mère non là je peux pas
dire ça mais pas comme ça
ça fait déborder une belle nana
première fois à troyes
et je vous mets toi c'est à troyes dans
l'aube donc c
est ce que vous êtes maso non vous
n'aimez pas les saintes j'aime bien les
ça j'aime bien un petit mais pas jusqu'à
la douleur a d'abord justin c'est comme
ça dans les petits frissons
c'est dommage que je vais le regarder
battus à celle fille
la prochaine question n'est pas obligée
de regarder mais est-ce que vous êtes
seaux d'eau je suis pas un passionné ah
bon non c'est vrai dans un des fois
quand
pour donner un petit peu de piquant
c'est à dire c'est un peu comme les
aventuriers pariant tiens j'ai parlé
dans ce pays
et oui vous êtes sur france 2 janus que
jon hamm messieurs est ce que vous
préférez ah oui un mec qui bosse bien
mais qu'un infidèle ou un mec qui bosse
mâles mais qui est fidèle
préfère ne pas savoir a essayé mais pas
fier c'est compliqué comme question
si vous étiez un défaut un défaut wii ou
la vache un défaut j'hésite entre
mais jouer votre groupe
si vous étiez une injure wattez jour on
croirait le cul nordiste
un supplice un supplice clémence arnaud
ce que vous avez de moins c'est que l ag
des pieds mais avant horrible et va nous
montrer en train de faire ça le pied de
yens
alors oui ce moment
ce qui vous plaît le plus dans la vie
non non on pouvait me dira la messe le
dimanche ça me fait autant plaisir qu'un
truc de cul non non non c'est non c'est
le fait d'être conscient se faire sucer
à la même
laurent c'est très très bien réussi
votre vie conjugale ça a commencé une
façon un peu violent
qu'au début c'était un ouragan qu'on
fait oublier ces trucs harkis sont
heureusement que je suis là je suis la
mémoire de ce pays mesdames messieurs
vous pensez à quoi là
à la question est posée sur stéphanie de
monaco ah ben oui quand il ya problème
l'opposition aurait aimé la musique j'ai
pas pu dire
m
vous aimez quoi quand on vous demande
des autographes paul belmondo oui c'est
tout m'était pas amicalement vôtre si
vous habitiez c'est les genres tout
genre
jamais vu ce film arceaux à cette source
êtes vous jamais des trucs vachement
bien
ça pousse
effectivement
votre père vient de kabylie est arrivée
en france à ces jeunes était boxeur et
puis un jour il a raccroché les gants et
il a pris le volant d'un 3 tonnes à 38 3
tonnes c'est par un camion s'est même
pas le poids d'une voiture
c'est ma mère qui m'a donné ce complexe
et quand j'étais bébé elle me trouvais
très très beau sauf les oreilles
décollées donc elle me mettait un
élastique il sorte de bonnet comme ça
qui me reconnaît les oreilles et l
enlever le matin savez tous à
vos plaques de libération c'est le
moment le patron et là monsieur jean
louis murat demain vendeuse millions
d'albums comme patrick bruel et ben je
peux vous dire un truc et vous en
parlerais plus de la même façon et ça
c'est logique par exemple mais bien sûr
que si et lara fabian vendrait cinquante
mille albums vous diriez c'est
formidable elle a une voix
extraordinaire sens
de tout du tout juste son haleine
voici ça se transmet
on a ouvert un petit salon de de châtier
dans le xviiie les châtier tout c'est ce
que c'est non c'est comme barbier mais
pour les chattes
et si vous dit plus simplement pas pas
comment on fait les bébés à la vie
explique vous expliquer il sait comment
on fait les bébés moi je prends une
bouteille de lait
c'est toujours un lexique à 8 ans qui
dit papa ma soeur elle dit en recul et
ça veut dire quoi
est ce que vous croyez qu'elle vis
presley est vraiment mort bien sûr
est ce que vous croyez à la
réincarnation j'aimerais bien y croire
est ce que vous croyez marine qu'on va
se revoir j'espère
non mais
vous êtes très bon en même temps si
gentil merci non mais c'est vrai c'est
un des plus beaux de la jeune génération
mais tu les veux tout
non mais c'est vrai mais je trouve qu'il
est magnifique ce garçon vraiment moi
c'est sympa c'est bah voilà le vrai
qu'on va sauver
est-ce que vous êtes exhibo
ouais mais en privé ouais mais même si
c'est quand vous êtes tout seul c'est
désormais
avec des proches en fait je m'en rends
compte que j'aime bien montrer mon cul
tout ça ouais
et hernandez vous regrettez pas d'avoir
pris finalement l'époque je crois qu'il
très bien à paris ouais bah oui ça pour
nous c'est bien
pires là où venait du défilé 12 million
la intéresse pure est bon joueur une
femme un peu chiante elle croit que
c'est elle qui joue
maintenant comme je dis c'était mon
meilleur jour de tournage là le
dépucelage les plans séquences et huit
minutes je suis nue et je me fais des
buts est
fâché avec l'acteur libero de rienzo là
non on pouvait pas se voir c'est pour ça
que vous avez tourné le dos
au but
embrasser s'est trompé bah oui
vous aussi vous dites sérieuses donc
sucer c'est tromper aussi
est ce que c'est vrai que vous
m'apportez nickel sens ni un slip ouais
c'est vrai
quand votre père vous demande pourquoi
vous n'avez pas joué aux genêts d'anglet
vous dit aucun joueur pendant mal est
donc vrai que dans votre garde
dès le départ vous prenez l'aviron
bayonnais est pavée genêts d'anglet oui
aujourd'hui parce que souvent vous ai
tendance à dire anglais où
j'ai envie de les airs car il est là
bien c'était dernier de gerde avoue
préférer partie avec une fille très
moche c'est un mec très beau bon avec la
fille vit vraiment sûr style désert
parce qu'on en fait à chaque fois si
vous partez sur une île déserte ça doit
être la même à mon avis parce que alors
vous savez le noble âge que
vous voyez quoi vous pariez fille moche
ou m non mais vous savez moi je m'excuse
mais très beau système
je pouvais être regardé en slip de sega
en slip de tibéri ou en slip de deux là
n'avaient
en fait pas forcément comme vous je
pense oui de suite
de cette caisse qui chante ça
gainsbourg non line renaud
elle chante ça et donne pas envie
et on a créé aussi la vidéosurveillance
une balade à levallois opté filmée mais
au moins on n'est pas agressé comme ça
oh je suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment
le remède pour agresser vous avez
j'habite à gennevilliers à chaque fois
je traversais levallois j'avais peur de
me faire agresser par votre police
municipale
jamais rien fait moi on sait jamais là
bas en tout cas vous avez été condamné
en attendant d'entre nous pour l'instant
ça va quoi la sec lui pour plusieurs
niveaux bonsoir j'ai appris trois quatre
mots comme ça il y aura ou miraoui
crainte shaoliang
vous êtes aussi vous êtes très beau
vous savez comment je m'appelle lee
décrivez vous physiquement
par aussi belle que coucou et très bien
quelle est la raison de votre appel
on t'écoute
lors ma fille il est en train d'écrire
une pièce pour vous avantage dehors
s'appelle
j'en étais sûr ça va être le sujet
principal de la soirée filles vont venir
avec un col roulé ce que vous préférez
en vous
que je préfère en moi
et votre futur d'amour la plus minable
aux nuits pour i way ça va je me suis
excusé
alors vous le rencontrer à l'elysée
matignon en droit aujourd'hui disparu et
alors il ya un type qui vient vous dire
monsieur gainsbourg ordonne que vous
aviez à sa table vous dites quoi ce
vieux con qu'il aille se faire [ __ ]
quoi ils arrivent vers vous il vous dit
le vieux con et vient à ta table espèce
de boudin c'était sympa comme
entrée en matière le vieux con
c'était vraiment
très beau
qu'est ce qu'il ya comment il ya ma
chaîne qui veut aider qu'ils bougent
apple
s'était bien david et fiona tan pourquoi
je n'étais pas avec les doors je n'étais
qu'un
avant elle a succédé compris la chanson
elle a été deux ans avec les frères
jacques pas non plus
ouais enfin pas des rôles non plus et
j'ai l'impression et semaines cet été je
tourne à un joli rôle avec lui mais j'ai
fait les essais auront le plus important
oui
michel arrêt de métiers des centres
ici il
a été un des inventeurs de la bombe
nucléaire française et vous vous êtes
contre la prolifération des armes
atomiques
bah oui il ya des contradictions dans
toutes les familles moi ma mère sonnait
les bons mais je me laisse pas donc cet
essai socialiste à l'époque jacques
chirac il aurait pu n'ont jamais réussi
à lui faire signer un plan de division 1
mais il venait souvent réunion je me
disais nous étions de même pour good
science pour n'était bien copains c'est
vrai qu'il a défendue l'appel de nos
jeunes g oui justement je vais tout vous
dire il voisinera comme beaucoup trop
réactionnaire pour lui chirac chien ce
lieu est ce que embrasser s'est trompé
non
ah bon puisque c'est que cette
philosophie que vous vous trimballez la
sais pas je vous demande mal joué mais
ça dépend du contexte et j'espère bien
que non
et sucer c'est tromper et pardon sucer
c'est tromper non plus non plus
vous ne dites jamais votre vrai nom
quand je dis jamais je sais oui bah
ouais c'est thierry tu ailles stresse
pas terrible non non mais c'est vrai
thierry lhermitte c'est bien pourquoi
lhermitte ben j'ai trouvé que c'était
sympa comme ça ça faisait un peu
solitaire
c'est pour ça que j'ai jamais cherché
qualifier votre vraiment parce que je
n'avais pas pseudo lhermitte on se dit
quand on s'appelle lhermitte c'est un
truc qu'on n'a pas pu choisir quoi
j'avais je sais je sais
alors c'est un film de pierre olivier
scotto avec vous avec claire keim avec
patrick bouchitey cyrielle clair et
thierry beccaro alors j'allais au nom
bécarre au si si il y avait patrick et
thierry taille vous êtes un grand ami de
jean marie le pen s'est pas désolé un
petit peu par la disparition du front
national du paysage politique français
sont ils se sont gâchées vraiment
ils ont déconné et voilà quand on a des
cantons et des bons amis comme ça ce se
brouiller pour une histoire de cul c'est
tomber
mais je crois qu'on va pouvoir vous
appelez le babouin non mais déjà j'ai un
petit nez de cochon non non non
j'espère que vous avez pas de complexes
physiques non à bondir l école des fans
un peu tout d'un coup
vous désiriez comment si vous retrouver
dans la situation de lulu c'est à dire
que les requins dans le film dans lequel
joue thierry lhermitte le roman de lulu
travaillez vous soyez de thierry dernier
la première virée c'est moi forcément
moi il m'a dit ah ben ouais ça peut être
l'autre c'était seule fille que je
connaisse qui ne soit pas tuer par
thierry lhermitte moi ce n'est pas grave
ce bal des fous je suis quand même nom
elle venait voulait dire n'est pas
attirée par les vieux c'est ça que tu
voulais dire les matières dans les vieux
votre première idéale
première fois à trois
bons à 4 non plus donc
j'arrête là c'est le chiffre pair
je vais pas la contrôler ainsi
pour servir un film c'est pas comme si
je venais alors la musique pour servir
du stomy bugzy pauvre tu vois donc tu
peux pas venir faire quand soif comme ça
parce qu'il ya du travail tout çà ou là
si j'étais acteur par exemple je devrais
me la péter un peu comme ça quoi
maintenant on vous voit à la télé à
chaque fois vous râlez justement et donc
je râle pas exact
on a du mal à se faire à votre lui par
exemple avant il était super rigolo et
tous maintenant il devenu acteur il se
la pète vous
vous êtes trio nous plaît vous n'êtes
jamais essayé non non non non la suite
encore je veux bien le croire est tout
petit la petit peu à bout 1
et papa c'est vrai qu'il faut plus
manger de danone ah oui ça c'est vrai
c'est vrai ce qu'à l'école on m'a dit on
mange plus de danone chez nous on mange
plus de bananes à rien pourquoi parce
qu'il faut partir et c'est mauvais ça
donne la chair
comment roule un joint
tiens va chercher la boîte là bas
est-ce qu'embrasser s'est trompé ça
dépend ce que dans la tronche embrasser
s'était pas trompé mais voilà
[Rires]
bon dernière question est-ce que sucer
c'est tromper
il l'a fait aussi
celui-ci ou se faire sucer se faire chez
ces gens là je voulais c'est là
là vous êtes en transe sympathisé je
n'aurais pas
ça a été pour moi formidable de tournée
en espagne de rencontrer un metteur en
scène comme bigas luna qui est quelqu'un
de très très aspire inspiré pardon
non c'est pas ton fait aspirer n'est pas
drôle mais nous l'attendons
millions par mois
qui peut plus peut-être aussi
vous connaissez le prix d'un litre
d'essence
volume ferrari modèles diesel le premier
il ya aussi des raids la beauté de cet
homme
je trouve qu'il est beau je sais pas si
j'ai envie de lui j'ai bossé pas loin
dans l'habit va se faire la bise
l'habitude
est ce vous êtes trop qu
il a du talent mais non en fait je veux
dire c est ce que vous êtes ton monte
comme nous
est ce que vous êtes gros lot
oui maintenant on va changer de place
de toujours sous l'oreille droite oui à
j'entends à 40% disent on vous avait le
visage un petit peu paralysés à droite
aussi non je ne sais pas disons que
c'est vrai que comme j'entends moins
bien droite je parle vers l'oreille
que possible que j'ai la bouche un peu
de traces et je me demandais toujours ça
va être sur l'axé du visage qui sourient
et le petit quelque chose
j'arrive à chanter en stéréo voilà c'est
la particularité anatomique que tu
semble ignorer il a 3 1 oui bravo
retirer
il le montre
[Applaudissements]
ni schumann aulas
excusez moi à quatre coups y aller vite
si vous trompiez votre femme vous lui
diriez
vous aimeriez avoir un nez
supplémentaires un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe supplémentaire pour un doigt
supplémenté un doigt oui exactement avec
deux filles ont plus
que si on a deux sexes vaut mieux avoir
une voix je suis plus proche
non monsieur si vous étiez en vente dans
un sex shop vous seriez quoi si j'étais
en vendant un sex-shop je serai quoi
nous faune en latex
si vous avez de moins sexy les fesses
pourquoi j'en ai pas hélas pas de sa
d'horizon des cantons série q quand même
dans le match
aulas qui sont bien
est-ce que vous m'aimez
à l'espace un truc là
c'est à dire se soit particulièrement
spontanée comme ça se trouve c'est un
film que les branches je sais rien
[Applaudissements]
jamais été aussi inquiet de ma vie
ça vient de la foufoune info cette fête
est une réflexion
je trouve très jolie
je sais s'il avait été retiré et il
aurait même pas je t'aime
pas gênant ça quand on est prince de de
vendre son nom à au commerce finalement
c'est une princesse de venise et peut
être tête de gondole
alors quand vous avez 24 ans vous
devenez séminaristes à rome
par vosges est à ce prix l'italien voilà
le ton band green chip emmanuel
si quelqu'un si quelqu'un traite alain
de la morandais de balladur ici vous
pensiez de kampala nourrissent
pas un peuple en bataille
tension laurent la vengeance
non
en revanche jean calvin alors recompter
vous je me repens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gp chez mon père j'ai bougé par
on peut pas changer de rôle
alors tu dis des fans un peu grave le
sénat
quelques rires voilà un mois d'après
jean fanta paroisse mal d'accord
notre dame de paris jacques thurette y
aller voir notre nom de paris bah ouais
j'avais pas notre dame de paris
enfin quoi défend tabarot h notre dame
de paris fait des vannes de cul je te
dis avec cette image
est ce que vous êtes venu en france
natasha st-pier pour trouver le grand
amour parce que mes amis mariage
tu veux quoi oui un croyant
quelqu'un catholique croyant ça tombe
bien je suis dans mon
élément c'est mon frigo
harry si alain delon était en face de
vous maintenant vous lui diriez quoi qui
ne me fait pas peur à la jetterait mon
gant si c'était encore pote permis aux
dix comme au 19e siècle
parce que c'est une manip inadmissible
ce qu'il a pu faire
ce que vous croyez que vous arriverez à
lui pardonner père
lui ferait du bien plus à lui d'être
pardonné par leila il un moyen bien mon
pardon
merci dans les dépendances d'une
sexualité choisir ben non ça devient pas
comme une drogue c'était comme une
drogue ouais c'était comme une drogue et
je m'en suis libéré ouais ça va mieux là
bas un fou et enfin t'as pas l'air
est pas puisque moi ouais d'ailleurs ça
se vaut
ouais ça se voit pas ce que je porte les
stigmates de la féminité je sais christ
et qu'on perd
ouais le blasphème est pas
qu'est ce qui vous rend bleus de peur la
moto moto taxi way ces derniers le
chauffeur pour pour me faire plaisir tu
vois il aller dans les embouteillages
moi ça me faisait pas utilisé et je
connais lui croit que j'étais content
vous aviez des dreadlocks à l'âge de 16
ans et la langue perceuse et toujours
avant de percer
et par amour est ce que vous seriez
prête à vivre à 3 way ouais ouais avec
une autre fille d'accord ouais un autre
garçon ouais super
est ce que vous seriez prête par amour à
aller le samedi dans un club échangiste
tous les samedis oui
est ce que vous seriez prête à devenir
son esclave sexuelle ça défie ce qui
fait
donc non
je sais pas si c'est drôle oui tu sais
que je suis comique
les armes des clermont-tonnerre ces deux
clés de saint pierre vous les avez
tatoué non c'est vrai ça oui ou
catherine sur la sphère noire latrines
on peut pas regarder impossible non mais
montre la gauche alors
est-ce qu'on embrassait s'est trompé ça
vous a brassé quelqu'un ou un bon copain
on est trop dans l'arizona avec talent
le tout non non non alors on s'est un
peu trompé quand même
ça ça lui conseillez vous oui c'est
tromper mais c'est être gentil est pas
trompé beaucoup
c'est râpé avec ses lignes ouais c'était
la dernière son show qu'elle a fait pour
l'an 2000 soit unie lendemain de
l'arrivée et puis je faisais un rap je
vais fermer les yeux pour me concentrer
sur le texte je fais des moves à la
blague comme ça où on imagine stams
théâtre ou aux manettes des couches
elles s'approchaient d'eux
est
tombé sur scène non l'avez vous aller
venger d'une certaine façon oui
j'ai vu tout de suite camille haut
niveau depuis le début d'émission il est
comme ça on tue ton
jeu c'est bien vous faites pas j'ai un
plaisir particulier ne pas le faire je
vous donne une dernière chance miller
[Musique]
jouera contre un petit peu l'histoire
l'action je réponds à les aider parce
que moi je suis déjà saoul alors
je m y signa une heure alors j'ai
picoler en attendant
c'est roland petit on est parti avec
roland petit j'étais jeune âge était la
rivale de six chambres j'ai jamais non
jamais
mais c'est pas tout zizi partie l
excuser moi en 49 avait pas plus âgée
que vous ici aussi elle a 10 ans de plus
génialement t d qui a joué dans des dix
longues l'egs avec fred astaire quand
même c'est vrai je joue au tennis avec
lui je jouais au au volley ball avec
gene kelly j'allais à la chasse au
canard
avec largué boyle est alors
pourquoi vous êtes une icône gay aux
états unis pour que vous avez autant
danic et
j'ai des amis gay dans le monde entier
mais pourquoi parce que j'ai jamais été
mariée je suis lesbienne
est ce que vous avez pu m'arriver nous
vous êtes dans votre maison dans le midi
tous assez calme les eaux
pourquoi pas assez ou parce que c'est
pas ma route pour tunis pour qui roule
roule
vous avez la foi mais ça oui je crois en
dieu je crois que tout le bordel qu'il
ya dans le monde il n'a pas été créé par
dieu mais par les hommes bon mais si
vous êtes peut-être raison vous savez je
souhaite ou des risques à la fois c'est
bien veilleux parce qu'on se dit bah je
vais aller au ciel mais personne n'est
jamais revenu il ya des milliards de
cadavre et personne ne revient
ça devient suspect
c'est parce qu'ils n'avaient plus
d'intérêt pour vous que sur moi parce
que je suis très fan de galawa donc
j'écoute ma femme vanessa paradis
est ce que vous êtes gros lolos gros lot
est ce que vous êtes recontre rocco et
ses frères encore que ces frais d un
gros merci fred et rocco siffredi ouais
qu'est ce qu'ils connaissaient pas rocco
siffredi non c'est un type qui est monté
comme un âne allons allons non non non
j'ai pas de détails vous dire mais c'est
pas rocco ses parts au coccyx poko assez
pour cause
c'est pas un conseil à communication qui
vous conseille sur votre coupe de
cheveux vous annonce qu'on ne lit plus
tôt c'est que c'est pas vraiment le look
qu'il faudrait mais ça m'est égal c'est
celui qui me plaît aux rédacteurs vous
êtes un verre intègre donc dépenser des
fonds pour faire face
votre film préféré parmi tout ce que
vous avez fait
est le film le plus nul que vous ayez
fait robert moi
vous parler de la vraie raison des
écoutes téléphoniques il fallait à tout
prix
justifié
l'existence de la cellule des barbouzes
de l'elysée qui n'avait aucune raison
d'être et pour cela et bien il fallait
faire croire que françois mitterrand
était menacée
et ils ont monté un faux attentat et
c'est cette histoire que je raconte
encore un le deuxième
[Musique]
l'état
et
mais si on m'avait dit un jour que
galapagos
maradona a dit en parlant de ronaldinho
je voulais une fois dans ma vie jouer
contre toi car tu es le dernier qui me
fait rêver dans le football
cela m'a beaucoup touché
c'était un moment spécial que je
n'oublierai jamais non j'ai quand il à
nice elle était défoncée aussi donc les
pendules à l'heure
il écrit ça pour vous grâce à ce joli
fleuve dans
[Musique]
leur faisait cette phrase merveilleuse
que je voudrais que toutes les femmes de
france écoute aimer un homme c'est
accepter de le voir heureux avec une
autre que vous
le dernier le même jour c'est vrai oui
incroyable
des liens ont été renseignés [ __ ]
maintenant elle est toujours très belle
elle a des enfants et
ses deux filles
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
aller dans une boîte échangiste tous les
samedis soirs à
on
oui
[Applaudissements]
qu'est la partie de votre corps que vous
préférez frédéric
m'habite
ya un truc m'a toujours surpris chez
vous c'est cette incapacité à tromper la
mère de votre enfant ou même dans les
situations les plus propices aux vies eh
bien oui cela 30 tout le temps je la
trouve tout le temps j'adore ça je pense
qu'il faut se faire sucer il faut il
faut déjà que faciale tous les soirs
c'est tabou chez vous les oreilles ma
vie mais jacques faciale ou fait 80
pages là dessus
sur comment s'essuyer comment remercier
vous préférez bien entendu frédéric
kadhafi jimena je préfère ma fille je ne
sais pas je me sentirais plus à l'aise
avec vous c'est vrai
graphiquement d'avis a fait fortune
à ma femme qu'on va solder tous les
crédits
vous êtes homo un peu
eva par rapport à ceux visés
tranquille
est ce que vous feriez un film porno
pour un million de francs dont 2
millions dont 3 millions 4 millions du
tout 10 millions et gagne bien sa vie
non messieurs
c'est fou quand même à ça je peux pas
c'est à dire il fait des livres avec
alain juppé mais il est quand il est
question de faire celle toujours
révolutionner mais j'arrive pas à faire
le sale tout frais je n'y arrive pas je
peux dire des conneries voir d'économies
ouais mais vous connaissez la punition
quarante ans après ça marche toujours
c'est incroyable vraiment largués quand
même un premier titre revient à sophie
way après j'ai crié aline pour qu'elle
revienne mais qui a eu de la gueule
comment ça va ça va comme quelqu'un qui
s'est couché tard
en effet j'ai fait du découpage que 80
du découpage oui c'est pour ça que j'ai
c'est parce que les découpages ces
découpages de cette nuit elle dit quoi
la maîtresse
vous étiez petits milliards semblait
cleantech la taille
à qui marilyn monroe j'aurais aimé avoir
des gros nichons fait un bond et la
terre entière
ouais
quelle est la dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher
découpage ouais
c'est l'allemand qui des coloriages
j'ai trois mois de prison ferme on a
droit à des visites non oui il faut que
vous demander au juge je pense que par
voie sexuelle maman dans les prisons
elle pas en france en espagne ah bon
mais il faudrait que ça vient d'en venir
à toi à moi je moi je serai
la prison c'est génial attention pas
totalement libre ya une petite grille
justement c'est ça qui est excitant
depuis quatre ans ouais je fais peur
avec tout ce qui m'arrive parce que
imaginez vous un homme m'approche vous
savez ce qu'il risque depuis quatre ans
alors
définir avec
lui judiciaire les a non je suis tapé
sinon on va faire un test on va le
tenter allez voir demain contrôle fiscal
plafonnant à fait désolé encourager des
graves toi je te mettrai
non j'aurais lendemain
regardez moi bien les nastase est ce que
sucer c'est tromper
je sais pas je ne parle pas bien
français
et le mot trompé qui n'a pas compris
alors vous attaquer à cette époque là
même sur votre vie privée
on a même dit que j'étais homosexuel
ce qui est beaucoup de choses que je
peux être être lesbienne
[Applaudissements]
pour apprendre un métier vite et bosser
petit souci et lee qui a écroulé de rire
on ne sait pas pourquoi qu'est ce qui se
passe et des meilleurs qui seront là
qu'est ce qui se passe il sait pas quoi
il parle et déclare que ce très grand
public et une [ __ ] à la place du cerveau
pauline et rocco
les grosses grosses lan ans par un truc
machine revient c'est casser la montre
est comme ça je pourrai juger sur pièce
on est bloqué tous les deux dans une
bergerie dans la montagne vous et moi il
ya la police française tout autour qui
nous assiège je meurs de froid vous êtes
obligé de me manger vous commencez par
quoi on ne peut pas arriver ça super est
bloqué dans une bergerie avec moi et
qu'on est susceptible d'être encerclés
par la police y aura un tunnel
[Musique]
c'est magnifique c'est le seul son qui
qui devrait entendre chaque fois qu'on a
un peu de repos et mondial on peut le
refaire pour l'émission concept jaune
version soit way intérieure et je
propose qu'on fasse mon émission comme
ça un certain nombre de pauses
absolument un super me faire penser en
régime c'est pas trop mon truc dont je
fais partie rigueur n'aime pas quand
vous vous foutez de la gueule
parce qu'en plus c'est ce truc en france
que si on chante c'était forcément votre
carrière de pas très bien et donc
sa carrière va très bien
jamais vu
et en même temps là la non mais
je pensais bien
bien bien
bien ça c'est fait alors
lorsqu'on avait deux
et vous venez de remporter la can le hot
d'or de la meilleure starlette française
alors vos parents c'est vrai qu'ils
n'ont pas très bien pris c'est normal
donc que soient vos quatre quelque chose
comme ça mais bon au fur et à mesure du
temps le barreau est pas loin
moi j'aimerais bien deux ans temps
qu'ils mettent un mec normal dans la
bande parce que parce qu'après nos
femmes nous elles disent ah bah oui mais
sur la cassette c'était plus gros ses
bureaux forcément cdh et
cd&v sur d'élevage quand même parce que
moi j'aimerais bien moi à la maison je
vais prendre moi quand je la prends
comme ça
j'en vois encore un bout un guide est
pas ça mais moi et si je mets deux mains
moi je vois plus rien mais il ya encore
5 qui dépasse c'est normal ça
bien alors aujourd'hui vous bien
persévérer évidemment
alors alors alors bien aujourd'hui
beaucoup
premier choc y'a pas longtemps ouais ce
qu'avec un membre de ma famille
j'ai vu les blessures tenue et voilà
la première vraie foi koala des
premières fois avec une fille c'était
pour l'anniversaire de greg
je comprends pas heureusement plus
souvent tard à réparer un petit cadeau
regarde votre mère est infirmière
non ma mère n'a jamais dit ah bon tu
oses mort
de quelqu'un qui travaillait dans la
décoration des vitrines et le travailler
dans la mode ah bon mais je vais refaire
un autre problème donc vous allez voir
vous êtes né à glasgow votre père était
capitaine dans la marine marchande votre
mère travaille dans la mode et se couper
des vitrines
et grand mère oui quoi papa il a fait un
bisou sur la bouche à la baby sitter il
a fait sa
grand mère oui ma soeur elle a dit
[ __ ] ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que c'est quelqu'un qui vous prend par
derrière
le pire cadeau qu'on pourrait vous faire
des vacances avec jean marie bigard un
concert de chants classiques avec la
partie des quais
je n'ai révisé nécessaire
le cancer ouais
j'ai plombé l'ambiance il faut un petit
peu de la forêt un petit coup de là pour
aider
oui
c'est quoi ton type de m j'aime bien les
humoristes qui se
destinent pas du tout
mes émotions c'est sympa comme dans la
vie moi j'ai pas trop apprécié
sincèrement de laon avaient voté pour
miss poitou hollande
j'étais assise à côté de lui moi
j'aimerais savoir ce que dit alain delon
a
fait une super affaire
qui est pourquoi je ramènerai pas chez
moi sur enfin
deschamps voit pas souvent mais je
regarde mon petit gradient bon j'ai de
la pointe du van toi j'ai mis dans mon
frigo c'est
le vôtre laghi à oui mais ça lui quelle
langue et puis que je vote pour elle
regarde toi tu descends
deschamps contre l'euro sa mort ça me
fait des dix ça me hérisse le poil de
penser à leur ont juste quand tu ta vie
ton nouveau front entamé
son salon
dernier coup de rein à
jacquard
commandes
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
mal et puis vint c'est de la très mal
pris
si vous préférez dans le sexe
l'habite
quel est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
les idées
la courbe faut pas toucher ceux de la
mer voilà j'ai essayé moi de l'abattre
on peut pas l'abattre alors elle devient
quand la connais elle devient un
compagnon qu'on touche pas allergique à
la cause c'est très simple et c'est pour
ça que j'ai parlé maintenant je suis en
forme j'ai peur de personne je suis fort
aux yeux tu pas de coke toi bon j'ai pas
un peu vite c'est pas un problème dans
ce rapide jamais car à pizza est
pourquoi je mange des légumes est en
pleine forme et
je suis
si vous êtes mégalo mais faut une tête
gonflée pour avoir pour booster son ego
parce que ce fait part de notre dans la
nature humaine si on n'est pas qu'on est
bien dans la vie si on dit qu'on est
petit qu'est-ce qu'on ait envie on va
rester petit je suis grand je suis fort
je suis beau shebab
obama
vous parlez aussi dans votre album de
mazarine pingeot oui vie de françois
mitterrand vous la connaissez aussi vous
la voulez rencontrer souvent tu ne peux
pas vous
j'ai eu deux trois fois au téléphone
mais déjà son numéro est pas mal
ouais c'est un début un an devrait
peut-être à quoi comme forfait au
téléphone
c'est vrai qu'à un moment sérieusement
vous avez des problèmes psychiatriques
est il besoin d'être suivi c'est vrai ça
ou c'est une légende il encore le
pansement
tu connais pas du tout aux masses
beernaert le neveu de wigan stein c'est
très beau c'est sur glane voilà est-ce
que je suis jeune et cette famille là
est ce que tu connais le dren gould oui
glenn gould le plus gaulliste grands
pianistes du monde n'était pas le cousin
barbara gould
assis paisiblement sans rien faire
l'herbe croit d'elle-même je la répète
assis va lui plaire assis paisiblement
sans rien faire l'herbe croit
d'elle-même là me pose tout seul
l'important dans l'existence et site est
totalement cool parce que quand je vais
à imsa dans les années 70 va toi tu ne
sais pas tout ça mais à formentera les
gens fumaient des tarp et de bi fait
mais ce que je veux dire miss france est
le plus vieux métier du monde
traite de [ __ ]
vous êtes expliquer tous les deux avec
je vais me gêne pas m'expliquer avec lui
pourquoi
je pense que la mairie
je peux dire c'est à dire ce qu'on peut
dire tout de suite c'est que non c'est
vrai c'est lui
on va demander à doc gynéco d'arbitré
donc oui
les arbitres et arbitres alors à mon
avis elle n'a pas couché avec
la doc c'est qu'elle présentera
publiquement tôt le problème
c'est mieux que la guillotine
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux